Rachel Hollis went from having her
brother commits suicide and she found
him moving to LA as a 17 year old to
pursue her dreams to hosting the highly
successful rise podcast and becoming a
best-selling author her book girl wash
your face spent more than 17 weeks on a
New York Times best seller list
she has four kids multiple companies
worships coffee like a deity into the
question of how do you balance
everything she replies I don't even try
need motivation watch the top ten with
believe nation
what's that belief nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend here's my take on
rachel Hollis's top ten rules of success
okay let's get that off with rule number
one get good enough I was reading
something the other day about like all
these stories like Michael Jordan or
different people where it's like he got
cut from his varsity basketball team or
all the stories of people who got turned
down the first time and that there's
this idea that Michael Jordan like that
the guy got it wrong that his coach got
it wrong or that with my first book like
the publishing world got it wrong no you
wasn't good enough yeah I wasn't good
enough yeah and he wasn't good enough
yet and you had we had to keep doing the
work to get to a place where we could be
here and that's the thing that I think
people miss is like you have to keep
going you don't even know who you're
gonna be you don't know who you're gonna
be half a dick a decade from now or ten
years from now because you you stopped
like why am i successful and other
people who want the same things and
started at the same time aren't cuz when
they heard note they listened I just
kept going I just kept going boom boom
rule number two ignore the opinions of
others from the time they're little it
tends to be that you get recognition
from your parents when other adults
recognize you as something so it'll be
like oh your daughter's so cute oh your
daughter's so sweet she's so funny so so
you'll learn oh other people's opinions
really matter and this is like what are
women just drowning in like what is
crushing women at other people's opinion
bingo they live their life terrified of
failure terrified to try terrified that
they're getting it wrong because their
mother-in-law will disapprove or the
girls that they went to high school with
a you know they're gonna see me on
Facebook and they're gonna watch me it's
crazy it's crazy because those people
that you're so terrified of their
opinion of you those people are not the
ones who will live with the regret those
people are not the ones who can't afford
to take their kids on vacation those
people are not the ones who are
struggling for it like all these things
that you want for your life but you're
too afraid to reach for because of what
other people will think those other
people are not going to be there when it
sucks and it's hard
that's all on you rule number three
become the-best-version-of-yourself wake
up it's a new day it's a new week and if
you choose it it's a new life you get to
decide right now who you want to be you
get to choose in this moment how you
want to show up in the world believe
that you're worth it
believe that you can believe that you're
capable of whatever you set your mind to
ask yourself how would the best version
of me live out this day waking up an
hour earlier and using that time for
yourself using that time to work on your
goal you have time you're just spinning
and doing something else success is
about choosing between what you want now
and what you want most imagine it in
detail see yourself eating the way the
best version of you would staying
hydrated if you are not taking care of
your physical body there is a 0% chance
that you're gonna become the version of
yourself you want to be working out
dressing speaking to others looking for
blessings throughout the day the way the
best version of yourself would do it you
are creating your reality right now you
are the only person who is in charge of
what happens next you've got to stop
procrastinating you've got to embrace
right now and you've got to fire
yourself up to propel yourself to the
future you need to own what you do you
need to own what you do see yourself in
detail and map out the day in your mind
if you cannot be the person you want to
be right now in this second right now if
you can't make the decision right now in
this moment you don't have a why that's
strong enough and if you don't have a
why that's strong enough right now you
won't have a why that's strong enough on
Monday if you aim at nothing you will
hit it every time don't leave today's
version of you to a random chance
choose who you want to be choose how you
want to be then live today accordingly
rule number four find your why the
number one thing I hear at book signings
is women who come up and they say it's
moms they'll say I've I've lost myself I
don't know who I am I don't know I don't
even know how to find my why I don't
know what my passion is I don't know and
I'm like who were you before you were
there mom who were you before you were
his wife who were you before you were
with your partner who were you what were
you into what did you love what lit your
heart on fire and a lot of times the
things that they loved they feel stupid
about they're like well at the dance
yeah exactly like choir I loved you know
but that like somewhere along the way we
got the idea that if we couldn't make
money at something it didn't have any
value in our lives but no dang it like
that's the point that's the point of
living like what are you doing if the
only thing that you have in your day is
how you show up for other people well
it's no wonder that you've lost who you
are well number five dream big are you
like a big dreamer like I want to make a
big impact you were just like I'm living
my life and I'm gonna start trying new
things that we have a massive dreamer Oh
biggest dreamer from the time I was a
little girl so I had a pretty hard
childhood why you're the baby I'm the
baby of four why was it hard uh my
parents marriage was abysmal like the
entire time I was alive and they were
together it was abysmal dad has a really
bad temper so I'm a I'm the daughter of
a Pentecostal minister and we were that
like everything looks perfect on the
outside
on the inside you know punching holes in
the wall screaming so it was really hard
my older brother was schizophrenic when
I was 14 he committed suicide and I
found him and that was really our family
was already such it was so hard it was
such a mess and that shattered
everything like there was no coming back
from the loss of him
and I from a very early age just thought
I gotta get out of here I gotta get out
of here and the only way I'm gonna get
out of here if is if I do it myself hmm
so that really started me on the journey
of Ryan guide when I was 14 I was a
freshman in high school and I was like
how do I take how do I get like how can
I graduate high school early how do I
take every class so that as soon as I'm
able as soon as I have the credits I'm
gone so I did I graduated as a junior
and I moved to LA without I couldn't
even sign the lease on my apartment I
will you know and I just hustled I
worked three jobs I shop for groceries
at the 99-cent store I just wanted out
and so I was always I mean that like the
dreaming like that carrot of dangling in
front of me like someday someday like my
big someday was someday you would be
able to walk into Target and buy
something there someday like the dreams
that I had like the big exciting thing
in my life was when I had enough money
to go to Subway on a Friday night and I
would get a 6-inch sandwich and like
Doritos and I would feel like a queen
like it did it I just I just kept
thinking if you just work hard and I
think the reason I wanted to start my
own company is because I felt like just
just like with my childhood I want to
live or die by my own sword I want to be
like if I fail it's on me but if I
succeed it's on me nobody else gets to
decide my destiny rule number six stop
complaining
how holding on to all the reasons all
the excuses all the justification for
why your life sucks tell me how it's
serving you has it made your life better
has it given you more access has it
given you more friends has it propelled
you forward has it given you strength or
did it suck the life out of you has that
made you feel strong did it make you
want to go run or workout or play with
your kids or did it make you want to
wallow did it make you want to hide
didn't make you want to get in bed did
it make you feel depressed tell me how
it's serving you coz I get it I know you
have your reasons
cuz the notes that I get are well Rachel
I want to grow my business or I want to
get another job or I want to be a better
mom but here are my reasons why I want
to play with my kids more but I want to
have a stronger marriage but girl
we all got excuses we can hold on to
them all day long or we can say you know
what I'm not giving that power anymore
rule number seven reinvest in yourself
well most people don't probably don't
know is that you really didn't make much
money for the first five six seven years
of our business Riley I'm just working
extremely hard coming up with content
you have multiple books yeah they
weren't making a lot of money of sounds
like no money no attention like this is
no followers yeah no this is I mean I
had I slowly I always had a community
but it was small and I wasn't obsessed
with the idea of how do we like I get
this question all the time like how do I
grow my social following I'm like serve
the audience you have add value to the
audience you currently have I I have the
community I have because they keep
talking about me to other people
sorry that's a side note but I yeah I
four years and here's every single penny
that I made I invested it back into the
company yeah because I knew that I
wanted to scale and I knew I wanted to
build something bigger and we had
revenue but not enough for me to take a
salary and I was really blessed and that
we could live off of my husband salary
for a long time which we did this is the
first time in years years and years that
I have put money like I put a check in
my bank account for the first time two
months ago
and I cried like a baby because it
wasn't it like I'm so blessed that we
were able to live off of Dave salary but
there was something like psychological
for me about being able to contribute
like I put money in our bank account I
don't know it was a big deal so today
yeah so I just kept reinvesting and it
really has felt like I don't know like a
snowball rolling down a hill like all of
a sudden it just took speed and and went
crazy after like pushing it for years
and years rule number eight grow from
hardships I think that understanding of
life is happening for you um sometimes
it's startling to people because they're
like wait you know your brother's death
was for you your brother had was
mentally ill like all they know but I
believe it's possible to find meaning
and or what happened that's right I am
the woman I am because of what I walk
through yeah and I love my parents so
much I think they did the best they
could with what they have but if it
wasn't for how much they struggle to
parent us I wouldn't be the woman I am
today
oftentimes when something when someone
goes to something hard they have this
perception that it made them weak and
man it made you a warrior like you yes
you have these scars you have these
scars on like these battle wounds but
don't miss the point don't miss the
message don't miss who you might be just
because the getting of these scars was
hard rule number nine
just try listen to me well you are
worthy and enough as you are right now
right now today you are worthy and
enough we have got to let go of this
of this self-inflicted crap that because
we have space to grow there must be
something wrong with us right now that
is a lie you should not feel shame
because you haven't gotten there yet
you should only feel sad if you are 97
years old and sitting on your rocking
chair and looking back at your life and
saying man I could have been how many
people in this world have stepped into a
bigger role for their life and where we
would be if these people hadn't done it
most people will not try because if they
do the work then they have to be honest
about all the ways that they need to
improve and that's scary let it go and
rule number 10 the last one before very
special bonus clip is keep going wait
you're you're stopping because it's
taking too long your dream your goal is
taking too long
it's a Julia Child ten years to write
mastering the Art of French Cooking her
work changed cooking for people all over
the world and launched her career James
Cameron worked on Avatar for 15 years
and it's one of the most successful
films in the history of the industry
ground was broken for the construction
of the Brooklyn Bridge in 1870 the
project took ten years and during that
time the lives of many of the men who
were building the bridge were taken and
lost along the way
but you guys the Brooklyn Bridge still
stands as a symbol of New York and a
hundred and thirty-seven years later it
brings 43 million cars to and from
Manhattan every single year none of this
was quick
I stopped obsessing over whether or not
I was any good and just focused on how
do I get better don't you get it nothing
that lasts is accomplished quickly
nobody's entire legacy is based on a
single moment but rather the collection
of one's experiences if you're lucky
your legacy will be a lifetime in the
making it's not taking too long
it's taking exactly as long as it needs
to going
Dave and I were in Dave Dave my husband
we were in Mexico I had just run the LA
Marathon
so it was like number one this is the
best shape I'm ever gonna be in in my
whole life
we got a few days away from our kids we
go to Mexico truthfully I've had tequila
I had a shot of tequila and I just got
in this new bathing suit and the top had
a monogram my family Southern Southern
women love a monogram at the time I had
about 5,000 fans on social media and I
thought oh I have a bunch of other moms
like I'm gonna show off this bikini top
and I never taken a picture of a bathing
suit before and so I'm like you do that
thing like Instagram husband like honey
take a hundred pictures we'll find one
and so he takes pictures and the very
last pictures I'm laughing because I
feel super like a most awkward and I see
the picture and in the picture I have
stretch marks all over my stomach
because I carried three babies and so I
start to zoom in you know that thing you
do in an iPhone where you like zoom in
I'm gonna cut it and then I'm like you
know what all the women who follow me
are moms they probably have stretch
marks too so I end up posting the photo
and I wrote something about the fact
that I wear a bikini like I wear a
bikini I have stretch marks and I'm
proud of this body and every mark on it
because there are so many women I know
who would kill to be able to carry
children and they don't have that
blessing and so I'm gonna rock a bikini
because this is what my body looks like
so I post the picture and this was back
my instagrams connected to my Facebook
and I posted it goes on both and I
remember sitting by a pool and at the
time I like went over to see you know
you like make sure it posted okay and it
had a hundred likes in like a minute
yeah and I had never I mean that's
nothing but back in the day that was
massive for me yeah yeah exactly so I'm
like wow that's crazy
and yeah yeah and like five minutes
later I had a thousand oh and then it
just and we sat by a pool of never
experienced anything like it my life we
sat by a pool in Mexico we would just
watch this photo go viral and it was you
know hundreds of thousands and a meet
like immediately people started they
would go to their bathroom and they take
a picture there stretch marks they're
posting their stretch mark photos and it
went everywhere
every when I say that every press outlet
in the world picked it up Wow everywhere
and I gotta tell you of all the things
that you want to go viral that's
probably not it like that was very
overwhelming but it really was the first
time that I saw the power of just like
being yourself and how much women
resonated with me being myself and
showing all of it not just the pretty
stuff raise your standard Apple at the
core its core value is that that people
have passion and not one drop of my
self-worth depends on your it's suppose
to mean
if you like this video check out the top
10 rolls I did on Mel Robbins I think
you'll enjoy that one too the link is
right there next to me continue to
believe and I'll see you there and so
the five-second rule is a mind trick
that's all that it is people have so
many theories about fear they talk about
while I'm afraid of success